today the family of two-year-old amari
nicholson came together
to honor his life thank you for joining
us on 8 news now on 5 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez now this is a
story that we've been following since he
initially went missing back in early may
after nearly a week of searching amari's
body found last wednesday near paradise
and twain
that's where kate houston is with this
emotional moment for amari's family
yes well just a few hours ago family
friends and community members
gathered at this growing memorial
outside of emerald suites now here you
can see
there are dozens of candles teddy bears
and messages all honoring a life gone
too
soon around 50 people gathered to
release white and blue balloons in
amari's honor
local organizations nevada child seekers
and bikers against child abuse
were here to support the family many
wore shirts with amari's face and the
message
fly high family members say they want
amari to know he was loved
and they will never forget him even
though we didn't get the outcome that we
wanted
we hope that this raised awareness about
how important children are
and how important it is that you protect
your children we want to thank las vegas
oh my god
even though there was not an amber alert
this community was the alert
this community little light that shine
all over the united states
now at this time the family says there
are no set
funeral arrangements now back out here
live while amari's father's side of the
family was here at this memorial amari's
mother
was not present reporting live tonight
from paradise and twain kate houston 8
news now